today on the matt walsh show another
police shooting caught on tape another
round of
of rioting once again the shooting is
declared a racist murder right away
as soon as the video uh comes out but as
we always try to do on this show we'll
look at the actual facts of this case
and see
what they say because they tell a
different sort of story also five
headlines including an nhl announcer
getting
suspended for an utterly innocuous joke
that feminists have labeled sexist
and in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about the incredibly misleading cbs poll
that has the media
accusing republicans of murderous
nihilism so all of that on the way but
first a word from
our good friends at rock auto look if
you need auto parts
why go to an auto parts store uh why go
through the hassle when
you don't need to make your life easier
go easy on yourself is what you deserve
a break is what i'm trying to tell you
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
is your odyssey an lx or an ex and then
they usually just have to order the part
online anyway so because there are so
many types of cars
so many different parts that are neat
it's impossible to keep them all stocked
that's why you have access to
rockauto.com
at your desk in your pocket rockauto.com
always always offers the lowest prices
possible
they're not going to change the prices
based on what they think they can
you know get out of you so why spend
twice as much for the same smart parts
there's no reason to do that
like say you happen to need a delphi
fg1456
fuel pump assembly for a 2005-2010
honda odyssey i definitely know what all
that means it could cost like 350
um dollars at a at a big chain store
that's the kind of thing
you could get at rockauto.com for 217
bucks rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto part
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts
from hundreds of manufacturers amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts you need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car truck
right walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so that they know that we sent you
rockauto.com go there now okay
well so let's get into this as we
continue
uh to live through this never-ending
groundhog's day
rioting and looting broke out in yet
another city this weekend black lives
matter
protesters in big scare quotes there in
kenosha
wisconsin burned pillaged destroyed
stole
all in the name of justice of course
here's what some of that looked like
take a look
rioters also burned an entire car
dealership so you can take a look at the
footage there
[Music]
and i think by far one of the most
disturbing incidents from this round of
rioting and really any of the writing
we've seen is the apparent attempted
murder of a police officer
who was hit directly in the head with a
brick during the melee
he's got brakes
now the rationalization the excuse being
offered for this latest round of rioting
in chaos is the police shooting of a man
named jacob
blake on sunday at this point not much
is known about the circumstances
surrounding the shooting
but we'll show you now the video that
has gone viral and prompted
allegedly all of this widespread writing
now media reports indicate that police
arrived on the scene
in response to a domestic disturbance
they tried to arrest blake
who resisted even after a taser was used
on him
blake then walked around his car with
multiple officers putting their weapons
at him as you saw
then he opened his door and reached his
side and he was shot seven times at that
point he's currently alive
though in critical condition neighbors
claim that blake was trying to break up
a fight
between two women after the before the
cops showed up
that hasn't been confirmed but uh it
does appear that blake
um that there were multiple warrants out
for blake for
for multiple alleged crimes were cops
arresting him
because of his involvement in the
disturbance or because of the warrants
that were out from or both
uh who knows apparently blake has had
other violent run-ins with police as
well including an incident in 2015
when he had to be subdued by a canine
unit after pulling a gun at a bar
now it's not clear again whether police
on the scene on sunday knew about his
violent history
or his warrants or anything else what
we're left with for now
is a man who chose not to comply with
lawful orders instead opened his car
door and leaned inside even as police
guns were pointed at him at point-blank
range
as always the dearth of evidence and
context has not stopped the media
protesters politicians from leaping to
drastic and
firm conclusions the governor of
wisconsin tony evers
has already tied the case to racism and
essentially accused the officers of
carrying out a racist hit on an innocent
man
evers tweeted in part tonight jacob
blake was shot in the back multiple
times in broad daylight and kenosha
wisconsin kathy and i joined his family
friends and neighbors and hoping
earnestly that he will not succumb to
his energy injuries
while we do not have all the details yet
what we know for certain is that he is
not the first black man or person to
have been
shot or injured or mercilessly killed at
the hands of individuals in law
enforcement
in our state or our country i have said
all along that although we must offer
our empathy
equally important is our action in the
coming days we will demand that
uh just that our elected officials in
our state who have failed to recognize
the racism in our state and our country
for far too long
okay needless to say a decent human
being
who is interested in providing
leadership rather than intentionally
fanning the flames of anarchy
would never use phrases like mercilessly
and racism
to describe an officer-involved shooting
before he even has
the details by his own admission but
tony evers
is not a decent human being or a leader
or a good man i mean these are really
bad people that are doing this
that are intentionally causing chaos and
rioting even after he knows that one of
his police officers was nearly killed
the people you know in the media and
politics encouraging the chaos
that again has nearly killed a kenosha
police officer also are not decent or
good people
putting the politics and narrative aside
then what should we really think about
this situation
you know well the first thing we should
keep in mind is that we've only heard
one side of the story
and there's quite a lot we still don't
know here's a rather significant detail
that's being treated as irrelevant
somehow
did blake have a gun in his car
media is reporting that he was unarmed
but they don't appear to have any
firm basis for that characterization
blake went back to his car
for something for some reason right was
it to retrieve a firearm
he has a history of pulling guns did he
try it again here
if he did then case closed no honest
person could possibly claim that a
police shooting is unjustified when the
suspect is reaching for a gun to use
against the officers
but what if there was no gun then we're
back to the original question
why was blake going to his car and
reaching inside
could there be any plausible or even
imaginable
innocent reason to resist arrest walk to
your car as police point their guns at
you and tell you to stop
and then open your door and reach inside
is there a version of this story where
blake's actions are justified or
innocuous
i can't see what that version would be
and more important than how i see this
or how you see it
we have to ask whether the police on the
scene had good reason to suspect that
blake was reaching into his vehicle to
grab a weapon
the answer there is without question yes
again
why else would he be reaching into his
car in that situation
if you can scarcely come up with an
innocent reason as you sit pondering it
on your couch out of harm's way
how can we expect the officers to
imagine an innocent reason while they're
in the thick of it
and even if they could imagine an
innocent reason are they expected to
assume that his actions are innocent and
stake their own lives on that gamble
you know anyone who doesn't understand
why police would want to prevent you
from reaching into your car during an
arrest need
only watch this dash cam video from a
highway stop in pennsylvania for that
for clarification on the matter and just
a warning it's very graphic here
but i think this is important because
it's it's additional context for the way
police are looking at this look at this
okay sir you're going 87 miles an hour
all those costs are associated with the
traffic citation
okay okay are you okay
all right i mean it's okay
do me a favor come over here
don't place your hands behind your back
hey place your hands
i got him keep the taser on
the shooter there daniel clary resisted
arrest
even threw zaps from a taser eventually
made it back to his car where he
drew his gun and nearly killed two
police officers the clery arrest
and the blake arrest are eerily similar
in many respects
except that in one case it's the cops
getting shot
in the other it's a suspect one excuse
i've heard offered for blake is that
he was going back to his car because he
wanted to get inside and drive away
well i would note that driving away
while there's a warrant for your arrest
and cops are attempting to detain you is
not a legal option
driving away in that case would be far
from innocent
also the family's lawyer benjamin crump
who manages to involve himself in every
high-profile police shooting in the
country
says that blake's kids were in the car
now this is supposed to make blake more
sympathetic but it does the opposite
why was blake bringing the officers back
to his car where his kids are sitting
he knew they had their guns out why
would he want to put his own children in
harm's way
and if his plan was to drive away and
get into a high-speed
high-speed chase with kids in tow
that would in itself be justification
for opening fire because
before he could get inside and endangers
children's lives in that way
i don't see any excuse for blake here i
see a number of reasonable
possible excuses for the police officers
now it's possible that more details
could emerge
that change the equation and if so then
i'll change my opinion to comport with
the facts
the protesters on the other hand form
their opinions completely separate from
the facts and no
additional evidence or context can sway
them from the conclusion they drew
within five seconds of seeing the
original video
that is why our society is falling apart
at the seams
not because of police shootings or
racism or anything like that
but because a certain very large segment
of the population
doesn't care at all about the truth
and it really is as simple as that and
that's what we're witnessing and that is
what
is burning our cities as we speak let's
get to five headlines
[Music]
reporting from cnn here white house
counselor kellyanne conway announced
sunday
evening that she will leave her post at
the end of the month while her husband
george conway said he was withdrawing
from the lincoln project both citing a
need to focus on their family
uh cnn continues quoting from kelly and
conway's statement
i will be transitioning from the white
house at the end of this month george is
also making changes we disagree about
plenty but we are reunited on what
matters most the kids
our four children are teens and tweens
starting a new academic year in middle
school and high school remotely
from home for at least a few months as
millions of parents nationwide know kids
doing school from home requires a level
of attention and vigilance that is
unusual at these times
um and then george conway also tweeted
that he'll be leaving the lincoln
project
um so
and this all happens uh while one of and
cnn says one of conway's high
school-aged daughters has generated
attention on social media about her
family and their political views
over the last several months now the
high school age daughter by the way
i believe is 15
and this is all newsworthy because of
conway's position
and the fact that she's she's leaving it
so you know fine that that part is
newsworthy but
all the rest of it the family drama the
stuff with the child
all of that is none of our business and
not relevant
to anyone else but them and the way the
media is using
a 15 year old girl to attack her parents
um well it's it's redundant at this
point to say
but the media of course has behaved
disgracefully not that they care but
just for the record once again it's
happened
and also you just so you know a 15 year
old girl
um professing to hate her parents
there is nothing new about that okay she
can she can
join the club with all the other 15 year
old girls in the country
now it's unfortunate that this is a
normal phase of of adolescence in in
modern society
and we could talk about why that is and
and you know because i don't think it
should be as normal as is but but it is
normal
um so i you know the fact that her her
parents are high profile
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with that whatsoever okay
nhl announcer mike milburyberry has been
taken off of
all nhl broadcasts for the remainder of
the year because of a terrible
horribly offensive thing that he said
while calling a hockey game
on friday we're gonna roll the tape on
that it's pretty rough i'm just
telling you hopefully i can play it
without bleeping it out i don't know
uh but this is really outrageous stuff
really bad
take a listen come here and play hockey
if you think about it it's a terrific
environment with regards to
if you enjoy playing and enjoy being
with your teammates for long periods of
time it's the perfect place
not even any woman had to destruct their
concentration
yeah that's it that's the whole thing
that was it
um milbury said that it's good there
aren't women there because
uh then they won't be disrupting the
hockey player's concentration
that was all that was the joke harmless
innocuous
nothing to it but that was shared by a
female
i believe it was a female nhl reporter
who was deeply offended
and then a bunch of other women all
chimed in to say they're deeply
deeply offended uh here's emily kaplan
another nhl reporter
talking about her own deep offense which
she feels so deeply and so offendedly
listen to be honest it's highly
disappointing it undermines anything
that any woman who is in this industry
does you know the athletic came out with
their 40 people
in hockey under the age of 40 and i was
just impressed by how many women were on
that list
whether it was from scouting ranks
analytics um now we have an agent who's
going to represent the likely number one
pick and then the lee kesten gaye
and when i look at meg milbury this is a
pattern of behavior this is not the
first time he's made sexist comments it
was so cavalier and natural the way he
said it
and he's in such a position of privilege
and power
there's so few people who do what he
does and i just think it's a shame
that we're giving someone like that a
platform when they continue to say these
things
and alienate large swaths of people who
can be hockey fans and can enjoy this
great sport
um and you know i hope that nbc takes
that into consideration
you know he said well there's no
distractions to women in the bubble and
i think he's talking about wives and
spouses but
also at press conferences and i think
okay i'm a woman that shows up for the
press conference does he consider me a
distraction if
i'm in the locker room like that's bs
that's my job
um so yeah you know that makes me feel
like hockey is not for me or i'm not
welcome and you know we have these
conversations a lot about race we do
have about gender we have it about
sexuality
and i think the important thing is that
we keep having these conversations
and we keep the league needs to keep
their eye on the prize and keep their
eye on the ball and keep doing with
initiatives even if we don't have change
right away
that doesn't mean we can stop oh my gosh
uh
you know this the irony here is that all
of this only proves
millbury's point all of these women
getting emotional and crying about
a joke or it proves a similar point i
should say
i think what milbury was getting at was
that women can distract men
sexually which actually is a compliment
to women if a man says that he's
distracted by your beauty
that's a compliment you know i think i
think
any any man in the country would love to
be told that by women
you know you know how any man would feel
if they walked in and there's a group of
women and and he was
there he's told that he's a distraction
because he's so good-looking um
that's uh that's a compliment so and
i sometimes wonder the type of women who
get offended by these kinds of jokes
are they getting offended because they
never hear comments like that and are
jealous
is there some envy going on i don't know
it's just it's one theory
but um there's another reason why a
group of men
might want to just have some time
without the girls
and the reason is this so they can joke
around and have some fun
and say what they want without anyone
getting emotional or taking things
too seriously now granted with the state
of masculinity in this country
that's no guarantee anymore just because
it's a bunch of guys doesn't mean that
you're not going to end up with someone
crying and getting emotional these days
but still the the likelihood is reduced
dramatically if it's just the guys
around
so as i said the irony is that these
feminists are only proving the point
exactly
and i'll tell you another thing if
you're a female sports reporter
and you want to be accepted
then pretty much the last thing you
should do is start crying
because a harmless innocuous comment
that you heard is sexist according to
you
like when you start ranting about male
privilege
do you really think the guys are gonna
want you around why would they
they're trying to play hockey why would
they why would they particularly want
someone around to lecture them about
about the patriarchy
and and sexism and male privilege and
and you know toxic masculinity
um it's just it's probably not something
they want any more than if you're a
woman and you're out with the girls
do you want a guy around to tell fart
jokes
like when you're sitting around at the
at the the winery or whatever you're
doing
is anyone at the table saying hey you
know i wish there was a guy here to
fart that's what we're missing
probably not so okay uh let's go to our
next so i think this is what is this
number three
uh i hate to be the bearer of bad news
here but you may have heard about this
asteroid that
might hit the earth the day before the
election day great timing of course but
turns out it's only six feet long and um
has less than a one percent chance of
hitting and you know so it's like it's
six feet
even if it hits what are the chances
that it does any significant damage
um so i'm sorry to ruin your monday at
this point i feel like the universe is
just
toying with us sort of tormenting us
dangling these asteroids in front of us
like
hey bet you like this wouldn't you sorry
it's hitting mercury instead and then
and then we you know to make it worse we
we look out at the night sky and we see
the moon over there
flaunting its crater covered body
bragging at all the time
and and we have to see that and it's
just really it's real it's difficult for
me i'm sure it is for you as well
okay let's go uh number four here police
arrested
two women in delaware who stole a
seven-year-old's trump hat outside the
dnc
um the boy and his mom were protesting
outside the dnc
and then here's the altercation that was
caught on tape by the boy's mom and led
to the arrest watch
back you get off my property get off my
coffee are you destroying my property
yes we are
you know that's a felony that one too
get away from the [ __ ] out get it
get it touch my head
get your hat back baby look at what you
just did to my
get your hat back baby get your hat back
baby
give me back my hat give me back my hat
give me back my hat give me back my hat
give me back my hat give me back my hat
give me back my hat
i'm telling you right now you're getting
you under you're gonna steal my property
i'll follow you in your car and get your
license plate
okay so i'm i'm glad that the the two
trashy women there
got got arrested and they were obviously
wrong for taking the boy's hat bullying
a seven-year-old boy when you're an
adult is
clearly i don't know how to explain why
that's wrong but
the mother is no victim in this let's
just be clear about that as well
the boy is a victim but he's a victim of
all three women
involved the mother and the two others
so let me just state this very simply
there is no good reason no good reason
ever to involve your young children in
politics
bringing a seven-year-old boy to
counter-protest
the dnc convention and dressing him in
trump gear
is an absolutely inexcusably crappy
parenting decision
i would never in a million years do that
i have seven year olds i go into
contentious environments where there
might be serious pushback whether it's a
protest or i'm speaking out of college
or something
you know um and uh
i would never bring my kid and it's not
that if i brought my kid and my kid was
attacked uh you know it's it's i'm
it's it's like it's not the fault of the
protesters for doing no it would be
their fault
but i'm not gonna bring my kid into some
sort of guinea pig i'm not gonna take a
gamble take a chance
i would never ever do that uh why
because i love my kids i want to keep
them out of harm's way
there's just no possible way that this
could benefit them
it's you know there's only downside
there's no upside whatsoever
so leave your kids out of politics just
leave them out of this garbage
and and using your kid as bait to get a
reaction
so you can film it for clicks which i
believe is what happened here let's not
be naive
is disgusting and i hate it i hate
everything about it
i mean notice how the mom actively
involves the kid every step of the way
so go get your your hat back baby go get
your hat back
no you get it back you're the adult what
do you send it a seven-year-old to go
retrieve his stolen property from an
adult
that would be like if i was in my house
and i looked out my window and i saw uh
you know
my kid's bike is on the front lawn i see
a man drive up and try to steal the bike
and i yelled at myself you know hey go
get your bike go get your bike go get it
i'll wait in here and film it
this will be good for youtube no um i
wouldn't do that because again i care
about my children's well-being i'm the
adult
uh if there's an adult situation i will
handle it
i keep my kids out of it and that's what
we should all do
let your kids be kids your
seven-year-old doesn't need to be
spending his nights
holding signs outside the dnc he doesn't
even understand what the signs say or
anything he doesn't know anything about
this
he's seven years old he should be
running around the yard you know making
a tree fort or something
even playing video games would be better
than this let him be a kid just let him
alone
for god's sake all right um finally
let's go
to this i thought this was just
wonderful in many ways and also
relatable
i've never related to lebron james
really at all
until i saw this clip
so you're holding the autobiography of
malcolm x along with alex haley i don't
know how far you are
into the book but what's your biggest
takeaway so far um
i kind of just started a couple days ago
um
but um i've read a lot of a lot of notes
over the years
it's my first time actually reading this
from start to finish
but just a very um very smart man
very very very smart man and basically
his words in the 60s and
uh and what was going on
is actually what's going on today still
him understanding the how powerful
the negro can be he use that word a lot
how powerful we are um
but we have to unite and uh we have to
be together we have to stand strong
because there's always gonna be
obstacles there's also gonna be
you know things that's going to be
thrown at us where they try to weaken us
they try to fill up make us feel like
we're not kings and queens
and it's going to come from all you know
different races and different
shapes and sizes and things of that
nature
and just a very powerful minded
gentleman that's that's just great there
i mean he didn't read the book at all
obviously and the first clue is that
he's holding it
during the post-game conference with
like why does he have his book with him
did he think he was going to be able to
read a few chapters in between each
question
um but like i said i relate to that
painfully so it reminds me of well
pretty much every day in english class
when i was
when i was a kid a teacher would call on
me so so matt we were
supposed to read chapter three of to
kill a mockingbird last night what were
your impressions of the chapter
um chapter three oh yeah well geez
whoo chapter three my goodness
chapter three am i right chapter three
it's just you know the main thing about
chapter three is just like it's it's
it's it's it's like
it's you're you're part of the way into
the story but you're not but there's
still so much of the story and so like
there's so much that's that's happening
that has happened and but there's a lot
that will happen
and so the main thing is just like the
three-ness of chapter three
is what jumps out at me you know
um and it never i i never got i got
better at bsing as i got older uh but
uh i never got much better than that
unfortunately and neither did lebron
james
and but i will mention just one note for
the kids uh if
when you have school reading you should
actually do it don't take your lessons
from me
and actually i discovered um when i left
school that i really enjoy reading i
just enjoy it when i'm not being forced
to do it and i can read books that i
really care about so it's funny how that
works anyway
uh so there's maybe uh we'll have to
check in with lebron james
in a little bit to get his full book
report we're going to go to
daily cancellation in just a second but
um if you haven't heard by now
joe biden is officially the democrat
party's presidential nominee for 2020
very exciting
we know this because they made me watch
his acceptance speech at the dnc last
week and it was
the worst
thing i've ever had to do and you might
say that speaks to a very comfortable
life
maybe or it could just speak to how
horrible the dnc convention was maybe
both
um they said that they had a good reason
for me doing this though
uh because i was you know i was hosting
all access live over at dailywire.com
with our all access members daily wires
most exclusive membership tier all
excellent members get to join these all
access live sessions where one of our
hosts
hops on every night to chat with you
both in live stream and in the comments
usually these sessions are
casual hangouts but on special occasions
we host watch parties like that one
this thursday august 27th we'll do it
again live stream and all access live
watch party for the final night of the
rnc hosted by michael knowles
the live stream will start at 8 45 a few
minutes before the convention kicks off
so make sure you tune in for that
dailywire.com
walsh right now to get signed up 20 off
all access with coupon code access
walsh with coupon code access to get 20
off your membership
today for our daily cancellation we will
be canceling the pollsters at cbs
uh now the media and the left were
engaged in more of their customary
performative hysterics yesterday over
the results of a
recent cbs poll as a quick side note
here this is this is yet another poll
for which i was not contacted i have
never been contacted about any poll or
survey ever in my life
neither has anyone in my family or
anyone i've ever asked
do they just pull the same 600 people
where do they keep these
are they being held in a dungeon
somewhere or maybe like a robotic womb a
lot of the matrix
but these are questions for another day
i suppose um in any case this poll
asked respondents about the coronavirus
um i don't know how they would even know
about the virus from their matrix wound
but that again is beside the point
one of the questions was this is how it
was it was framed
the number of us deaths from the
chronovirus has been
and then the options are acceptable or
unacceptable
and as you can see 50 percent of
republicans said it was
acceptable while 90 of democrats bravely
took a stand and said
no no death is unacceptable entirely
unacceptable i will not accept it
and i guess this explains why i don't
get called for polls because
if they had asked me i would have said
option
c the poll question is unacceptable
because the poll question is
unacceptable because it's it's stupid
and incoherent and has absolutely no
function or purpose except to trap
republicans into saying
exactly what 57 of them did say
acceptable
what what the hell could that possibly
mean in this context to call something
acceptable is to say that
you accept it and to say that you accept
it is to say that you will allow it you
will tolerate it you will bear it
so what else could a death toll be other
than
acceptable phrased another way what
choice do i have but to accept it
1500 people died when the titanic sank
is that acceptable to me well
it's sad i don't like it i wish it
hadn't happened
but now that it has do i accept it i
suppose so what other choice do i have
if i say no i don't i don't you know oh
no i don't accept the titanic death toll
okay then
what does that mean what does that
amount to can i cause those lives to
regenerate by refusing to accept their
laws will the ship
emerge from the icy depths fully intact
because matt walsh has announced that
it's it's sinking was
simply unacceptable to him everything
that has happened in the past
is acceptable to you because it must
be it might also be horrible infuriating
outrageous tragic terrible a million
other things but
it must also be acceptable because you
have literally no other option besides
begrudging acceptance you know try
conducting a pole
on an airplane after both engines have
failed and it's plummeting to the earth
ask the parent the passengers if gravity
is acceptable to them
i'm sure a lot of them will say no but
sadly gravity will still be gravity and
they're still going to be going down
whether they accept it or not so the
dichotomy of acceptable versus
unacceptable is meaningless here
there's a reason why nobody ever pulls
you know to ask how many cancer deaths
are acceptable or diabetes deaths or
heart disease or car accidents
if they did you might think on one hand
no deaths are acceptable
death itself is unacceptable but on the
other if you possess even the slightest
capacity for honest self-reflection and
assessment
you will see that inevitabilities don't
care whether you accept them or not
now you could argue that what this
question is really trying to ask is
whether the respondent
respondents think the response to the
coronavirus
was acceptable whether more could have
been done whether steps could have been
taken to save some of those lives
whether the policies put in place were
effective or not et cetera but
those are not the questions that were
asked those questions
could have been asked have been asked
but this question is different this is
asking
whether you accept what has already
occurred
they might as well ask you whether you
accept that the color blue
is not the color red you might say that
i'm playing a game of semantics here
splitting hairs missing the larger point
but if you say that i would say that it
is you who is missing the larger point
because
the fact that the question makes no real
sense is
exactly the point it's why it was posed
in the first place
there is no right answer to a nonsense
question
and there could only be one reason why
pollsters would
pose a nonsense question it's because
they can
frame the answer however they want it
becomes like some sort of strange
reverse
rorschach test type of thing but let's
pretend for a moment
that this question had been posed about
the future
rewind the clock back what if they'd
been asked whether 170 000 potential
deaths
in the future would be acceptable
maybe if you want to be generous you'd
say that that's what the poll question
is getting at it's asking
if you could go back in time to before
the deaths occurred
would you consider 170 000 plus deaths
acceptable
of course again if that's what they
meant to ask they could have asked it
but let's pretend they did
would that make more sense no
not at all past deaths obviously can
only be acceptable to us because they
are facts
and one can only accept facts or shut
his eyes and think happy thoughts
instead but
not a lot not lot not a lot of good that
does what about future deaths
those aren't facts yet can we talk about
acceptable versus unacceptable in that
context
no we can't or we can but it will be a
totally arbitrary and meaningless
conversation
170 000 deaths is a lot you say it's
unacceptable
fine what amount of death from the
chronovirus would have been acceptable
to you
and how did you arrive at that figure
would you have insisted that
zero people are allowed to die from this
even one death is unacceptable
okay but was that ever an option was
there ever even a theoretical
possibility of
no one in america dying from the global
pandemic probably not so
what is your acceptable figure and how
did you arrive at that number
let's pull something out of the blue
let's say 50 000. would that have been
acceptable
if you say yes then i'd have to ask how
you know that 50 000 was ever in the
cards ever possible
and whether it was or wasn't 50 000 is
still a lot
it sounds horrible to say that 50 000
deaths are acceptable
just like it sounds horrible to say that
say that of 170 000 deaths or any amount
of death
there just is no way to ever attach the
word acceptable to death
any death in any number that won't sound
bizarre callous and somewhat sociopathic
that's because again acceptable versus
unacceptable is a meaningless dichotomy
in this realm
and wherever we draw the line between
the two it will be unavoidably
arbitrary but i do think there's
something deeper going on here
deeper than a dumb and pointless
question
our reaction to this pandemic to this
confrontation with a mortal threat
and thus a confrontation with the fact
of our own mortality
has revealed again that we are a culture
totally unwilling to accept the reality
of death or confront it in an honest way
in fact it turns out
lots of us really do think that not
accepting death is a viable option
which is why many people support the
idea of locking down all of society and
hiding in our homes indefinitely economy
be damned thousands of small businesses
be damned
personal liberty be damned constitution
be damned everything be damned
as long as we can avoid at all costs
any amount of physical risk we cannot
bring ourselves to face the fact
that this disease is out there that will
probably always be out there in some
form
and that people will die from it you
know that we can
and should take steps to mitigate the
risk to some extent but that society
still must function
and that as society functions people
will die
from this and a million other things we
can't face that because we're so
terrified of and overwhelmed by the very
idea of our own mortality
you know we will not say to ourselves i
might die
and i accept that and we mock anyone who
does say it as though they're suicidal
nihilists when in fact
those you know they're saying it are
only acknowledging
a fact that applies to us too no matter
what we do
because we cannot escape mortality
anymore that we can escape the waves on
the ocean while we sail across
it another example of this feeble
refusal to accept the inevitable
um can be found in climate alarmism
alexandria casa cortez this weekend
tweeted in response to the news that two
hurricanes
might strike the gulf coast at the same
time and she said talk to me again about
how a green new deal goes too far to
address the problem
this is a woman who really believes that
a piece of legislation
can stop hurricanes it's not an
exaggeration to say that climate
alarmists like her
think we can legislate hurricanes away
they believe we can raise our hands and
halt the winds and calm the seas like
gods
our utter powerlessness in the face of
these natural forces is too much for
them to accept
our smallness and finitude and
vulnerability against the scale of the
whole earth and cosmos
is so terrifying they try to reduce it
all down to a problem for bureaucrats in
dc to handle
they might as well hold a congressional
hearing to come up with a strategy to
stop our galaxy from colliding with
andromeda in five billion years
the refusal to face the inevitable and
the unstoppable
especially that most inevitable and
unstoppable of things mortality
has been a driving force for human
society since the birth of consciousness
but in our society in particular the
force is very strong
and never has that been more obvious
than right now
and that is why wait who was canceled at
the beginning of all this oh yeah
cbs pollsters are canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2020.
joe biden declares democracy on the
ballot blm threatens to kill more people
and president trump declares war on the
deep state
over the wu flu check it out on the
michael knowles show